I want to talk a little bit about how we
think about innovation at amazon.com and
give you a couple of examples from the
world this is the wiffle ball and the
guy his name is David Nelson Mulaney and
in 1953 he took a Cody perfume package
and out of frustration because his son
had broken a window with a regular
baseball and created the wiffle ball his
son named it this woman is named Betty
Nesmith Graham and she is you will know
of her accomplishment in just a moment
if you don't recognize her name but she
was an executive assistant in the time
when typewriters transitioned to film
cartridges from ink ribbons and and she
was very annoyed she wasn't an
especially was a great executive
assistant but she was a rather poor
typist and she was annoyed by her
inability to erase her mistakes with the
film cartridges so she invented liquid
paper which after let's see by night she
did this in 1956 in 1975 she sold liquid
paper to the Gillette corporation for
forty seven point five million dollars
so she did pretty well with her
innovation and by the way it was just
white paint so
there was no very very clever person
because there was no you know special
chemistry involved here this this was
not a high-tech solution and but
extraordinary observation of a problem
and a solution now so sometimes people
see the problem and the problem is
really annoying them and then they
invent a solution sometimes you can work
this from the backwards direction and
and in fact in high tech I think a lot
of the innovation sometimes comes from
this direction you see a new technology
or there's something out there some new
understanding in the world and you work
backwards from a solution to find the
appropriate problem carbon dating is a
little bit like this so you know they'd
always wanted this solution to be able
to date things but until they really
understood the radioactive decay that
wasn't possible to come up with that
solution so some new understanding some
new concept enters the world and that
there are a lot of things like that in
high-tech now their critical ingredient
for anybody who would be innovative is
persistence and there are many examples
of people being persistent in the world
in order to make something work this is
this is one of my favorites wd-40 was
this a small team a small company of
three people got a government contract
to develop a some kind of coating that
they could put on the skin of Atlas
missiles while they sat in their silos
to keep them from rusting and they they
worked on this for a long time to find
this right compound that would do this
job and and finally did it now it turned
out that the Atlas missile market was a
fairly small one
so that the company wasn't really able
to make much progress now what does
wd-40 stand for it stands for water
displacement 40th to 10 and that's the
name right out of the lab book when they
did all this work to invent wd-40 so
when they properly recognized to the
size of the Atlas missile market they
started to think about a different
business plan and the company was called
the rocket Chemical Corporation and it
was their only chemical it was their
only product and so about 10 years later
they renamed the company the wd-40
company and you know the rest is history
one of the most pernicious obstacles to
invention is learned helplessness so
people get the problems that you
encounter
if you encounter them for a long enough
duration humans and actually biology in
general but humans in particular so
remarkably adaptive that we pretty soon
see right through the problems we don't
even notice them and so great inventors
and people who they're very good at you
know ordinary things bother them you
know they wake up every morning and take
a shower and they think this shower is
terrible you know and but if but it's
very difficult to do that
to kind of push through this learned
helplessness you get used to something
here's an example this woman is named
Mary Anderson and Mary invented the
windshield wiper
let me get Marius paper out here oh well
I don't know the story well enough but
Mary was this was around 1913 and cars
didn't have windshield wipers in fact
when it rained people would pull off to
the side of the road and they would take
a rag and clean the windshield off and
they'd drive another mile and and repeat
this process and they thought nothing of
this and Mary you know looked at this
and she said that it's ridiculous and
that there must be a better solution
than stopping every so often and
cleaning off your windshield with a rag
and so she invented the windshield wiper
and she was roundly criticized that this
was a ridiculous thing and people had
all sorts of reasons why it wouldn't
work primarily that it would be a huge
distraction for drivers to have this
thing going back and forth in front of
them and but she persisted and and and
this happened very quickly
within ten years of her invention of the
windshield wiper
they were standard equipment on all cars
so with one of these things that you
know and actually even though people
pooh-poohed it once they tried it
they're like no it's stopping not having
to stop every mile with a rag it's
actually a pretty good idea and so Mary
definitely got the last laugh and this
is one of my favorite inventions and a
fantastic example of learned
helplessness as you know toilet paper
was invented and people said the year is
in the mid 1800s guy named Joseph Getty
1857 invented toilet paper this is the
first toilet paper it's hard to read but
it says many people have wooed their own
destruction physical and mental by
neglecting to pay attention to ordinary
matters
rarely an advertisement just one find
such a profound statement and so but
this is one of those things people
didn't know they needed toilet paper
until Joseph guiity invented it and then
very shortly thereafter they began to
realize that it didn't know how they
lived without it and it's certainly
difficult to consider going back now
let me talk about it let me make one
very important to disclaimer right up
front that amazon.com does not claim any
inventions nearly as important as toilet
paper this is this is clear but we have
been working hard on innovation and
we've done a bunch of different stuff
and I want to I want to and we have been
for the whole nine and a half years of
our of our history and I want to talk a
little bit about that so first of all
it's sometimes useful to take a little
time travel trip and move backwards this
is what amazon.com looked like in July
of 1995 I think this is actually a
screenshot from August and and it you
know it's changed a lot since then this
is by the way I wrote all of this HTML
myself no really please hold your
applause there's no need
really you're you're embarrassing me and
the this notice some of the very obvious
problems that this has for example
there's no search box on this page the
search box is a click away you have to
click on I think you know 1 million
titles will take you there or search
Amazon coms a million title catalog so
this is what the website looks like
today and we invest about 250 million
dollars in the last year but about 20
million hours a year for several years
now 250 million in the last year on
technology and content development and
so the website should be better
sorry significant sums of money the
company has generated over the last
three years nine hundred and fifty
million dollars in free cash flow in the
context of investing six hundred and
fifty million dollars in technology in
that same period of time so we've we've
you know we've gotten smarter about a
few things the search box is now you
don't have to click it's not one click
away it's right there and there are a
bunch of other things going on here but
but the point is the the the you lose
track in the moment of how much
innovation there is over a nine year
period one of the things that is very
important at Amazon that we're
constantly trying to do is reject this
either-or thinking that really is at the
heart one of the big impediments to
innovation I'll give you a simple
example which is in customer service
it what the what we want to do is make
the service better so that we can have
the ACSI rating that you're talking
about of eighty eight which we are very
very proud of and that's a very they do
they have a panel of like sixty thousand
customers that they pull so it's a very
statistically significant kind of result
and something that we we do you know
it's it's a metric that people have
worked very hard not specifically on
that metric but on the things that lead
to it so it's a great for us it's
something that we you know are very
proud of this we get a lot of customer
contacts and one of the things that we
would like to do is minimize customer
contacts and in order to save money so
they can offer people lower prices but
still offer great customer service and
so how do you solve that problem well
you do it a couple of ways one is you
eliminate defects and eliminate root
causes of defects because if customers
are contacting you they probably didn't
want to I think actually the number four
reason we get contacted it is to say
thank you and so that's kind of nice we
don't need to eliminate those contacts
but most of the contacts that we get or
not to say thank you
they you know sometimes come in all
capital letters
you know and so if you can eliminate the
defects you're gonna save money because
you're not going to have to handle the
customer contact at all and you're gonna
improve the customer experience so
there's no trade-off in reducing defects
and the more the closer you reduce
defects to the root to the root cause
the the more that's going to be true
you're going to both improve the
experience and save money no trade off
but the second thing that we did is
build customer self-service and this is
our you know this is the page where you
go to to do customer self-service and we
let people cancel their own orders we
let people you know consolidate orders
and do all sorts of things since change
their shipping address and so on and so
on and check on the status and and when
is my thing going to arrive etcetera etc
and that has really empowered customers
and what you find is when other in other
industries like the hotel industry
Embassy Suites often wins the best
customer service award in in hotels when
they pull heavy hotel users and of
course they the the secret to Embassy
Suites winning that is that don't
actually have any service it's all
self-service and so people when they're
serving themselves think the service is
terrific and so you have the buffet out
and if the buffet is out and the food is
free so you just take the food and you
leave this is just not much that can go
wrong and and and that that really helps
so that's something that that we've
worked hard on it it's an example of
rejecting either-or thinking and we have
been able to reduce contacts over the
last seven or eight years by eighty-five
percent which is a huge reduction and
that that level of that driving down
contacts per unit continues the other
thing you have to do if you're going to
innovate and that we try to do at Amazon
accom is maximize the rate of
experimentation so and if you're going
to do that you have to make sure that
your cost of doing experiments is low if
your cost of doing experiments is high
then you're only going to get to do I
think the company is only going to do a
few experiments per year and if you're
doing a few experiments per year the
you're going to have to do some kind of
global prioritization to see which kind
of experiments you can do and that's
going to have a couple of downsides one
is you're not going to do much
experimentation but the second is that
the best most inventive people and your
organization are going to become
frustrated because they're gonna have to
get ultimately if we can one can only do
three experiments a year then if you
wanted to do an experiment you'd have to
get my permission to do it and I'm not
scalable so so that is going to put a
huge impediment in the way of invention
and if you want on the other hand if you
want to make experimentation that
everybody can do it and it doesn't take
you know sort of the you know the the
institutional apparatus doesn't have to
approve every experiment then you need
to make the cost of experimentation low
if you're still going to make it a
reasonable thing to do and and and not
irresponsible
you can't just let if the cost of
experimentation is high you can't just
say yeah this is gonna cost hundred
million dollars to do this experiment
but go for it so the getting that cost
low is is key and one of the things that
we've done over the years has put a lot
of effort into making sure that our
infrastructure are in the framework that
operates our website in other parts of
our business really make it easy for
people to do experiments in a
self-service way without coordination
with the institutional apparatus one of
the great things about operating on the
web is that you have you have so much
the ability to collect data and all many
things that in the physical world
because the cost of experiment would be
high you have to use judgment to decide
those things you have to use intuition
to judge those things because you can't
do the experiment at realistic cost so
you end up having to argue over it and
on the web you can often just know the
answer so you know a simple example this
was a control this page and you'll see
the difference here a new line is going
to pop up one it delivered tomorrow May
5th order in the next two hours and 53
minutes and choose one day shipping at
checkout so this is experiment we did
about a year ago and
percent of the customers saw it this way
and 50% of the customers saw it this way
and you can just literally measure the
impact that this has on all sorts of
important metrics you know first and
foremost sales so you can see this
telling people that they should order in
the next two hours and 53 minutes
increase sales or decrease sales and and
and and and and buy how much is this
worth doing and is it worth pushing
harder on and so on and so on so being
able to do that kind of experiment and
not having it be a big deal is really
wonderful here's another example an even
simpler example this is you know
customers who bought this also bought
something that we're well known for and
this has been improved over the years
dramatically here's a small example this
was tested - oh that's not the one I'm
showing here is we added series to it so
that you're you know you're here's an
actual individual DVD but here's series
from different things that was a
successful experiment so it stayed one
of the experiments that we ran with this
customers who bought this also bought
was it seemed very intuitive that if
this works well then adding images might
make it work even better so we added
images turned out that it didn't make it
work better it made it work worse and
even though that's a little
counterintuitive I mean it to me I can
see it both ways but that's the that's
kind of the whole point here you know
you have you have your a priori guesses
but then you actually validate them with
real data
here's another try at images since the
this the the when this one didn't work
it was oh maybe it's too clunky maybe
it's pushing things down below the fold
so this one this one was tried but it
also didn't work as well so we stuck
with this one the other thing we try to
do at amazon.com is have a customer
centric obsession instead of a
competitor obsessed a point of view and
there are by the way that's not clear in
all companies at all times that this is
the right strategy competitor focus and
in fact close following strategy
can be very effective in certain
business environments and there's
certainly nothing wrong with it with the
with with that but in our industry and
and given the DNA that we have inside
the company the kind of people that
we've attracted over time our people who
like to invent people who like to
pioneer so you know we'd have we have
the wrong culture to be close followers
so there's part of this that you know we
are what we are and we and and and and
we kind of have to stick with that and
make the best of that I actually think
in our space this is also very handy
because the rate of change in the online
world is so rapid that closed following
doesn't work as well as it might in a
more stable industry that the change is
more slowly over time but one of the
things about these fast changing
industries is I often get asked by by
audiences if I take you native period
you know what's gonna change in five to
ten years one of the questions that I
rarely get asked and I think is at least
as important of a question and maybe in
some ways an even more important
question is what is not going to change
over the next five to ten years and
that's another reason why customer
centric strategies can be so powerful
because competitors focus strategies
have to change law the competitive set
changes so rapidly over the last ten
years our competitive set has changed
and the technologies have changed so
many things change but the basic drivers
of our business the core things that
customers want do not change you know we
know that what customers want our
selection low prices and convenience and
I guarantee you that ten years from now
they're still gonna want selection low
prices and convenience we are not going
to wake up ten years from now and have
customers say this is all well and good
I love this thing Amazon to come but
could you make it a little less
convenient it's just not going to happen
and so so when you work on low prices
you have to figure out inventive ways to
do that and there are inventions a
difference at different granularities
there are the a lot of the most
important invention happens at the
finest granularity
so incremental improvements in unit
productivity are critical so can you you
in in in our fulfillment centers you
know which are about so we have about
seven million square feet of fulfillment
centers each you know the each one is
about 700,000 square feet these are huge
buildings you know kind of corner to
corner there half a mile on a side and
so how do you pick you can order any two
items we have a million more than a
million items in stock which to put that
in context you know a Barnes & Noble
superstore has about a hundred and
twenty-five thousand items a Costco or
Sam's Club has about four thousand items
a big big-box electronics store has
about seven thousand items so over a
million in stock items is a lot of items
and you can order any two of those items
and before 6:30 p.m. Eastern Time if you
if you could if you order them before
6:30 p.m. Eastern Time we will ship them
that same night so and those two items
might be on opposite sides of this big
fulfillment center so we have to there's
a tremendous amount of work and very
sophisticated computer algorithms that
go into optimizing the pick paths so
that we can pick those items and get
them into the same box at low cost it's
easy to do that if you're not worried
about optimizing cost it's very
difficult to do that if you are
concerned about optimizing cost so those
kinds of incremental improvements taking
those pick path algorithms and making
them modestly better and doing that
every day and and the key to doing that
kind of invention is to make sure that
you have small separate empowered teams
that aren't subject to a bunch of
dependencies in the rest of the
organization they know what they're
trying to achieve and they go about
making those incremental improvements
day in day out month in month out they
have to be able to answer the question
which in it's amazing you'll find that
this is very common in in in the
business world that people often cannot
answer the question how do you know
whether you're getting better or not at
this particular thing and the picking
the granularity of where you ask that
question is the trick I mean it's very
easy you know on the distant outputs if
you look at you know something like free
cash flow or revenues
those kinds of things people know
whether they're getting better but those
things are not directly actionable you
can't you know assign some team and say
look go drive free cash flow it's just
too easy and it's it's - it's easy to
command them to do it but they won't be
able to do it I mean it's a useless kind
of things to ask for and then on bigger
granularities so one of the things that
we also observe is that used products
can have much more value proposition for
customers so we invite third-party
sellers to compete against us on our
prime real estate which is our detail
pages that's an invention that also not
only adds a lower price but selection -
so you go through all these things
selection one of the things that we've
done recently to increase Bret this
lecture at Amazon is again invite these
third-party sellers in this works in all
the categories where we operate and in
some of the newer categories like
apparel it's a huge part of the strategy
convenience the most recent thing that
we've done to increase convenience is
for our heavy customers which is
something called Amazon Prime and Amazon
Prime is a we do only launched this a
week ago and it is a $79 flat fee
membership you pay $79 a year and you
get two day shipping for free and that
is a the idea here is to take what might
be an indulgence for people getting next
day air shipment or second day area next
day next day air is just three dollars
and ninety nine cents an item once you
remember and take something that they
might perceive as an indulgence
transformed into a fixed cost and then
once people can view it as a fixed cost
so well why not have two day shipping on
my items and so for a certain segment of
customers this is a very attractive
proposition and it's for it specifically
for that segment of customers where
convenience is most valued so you know
there's another segment of customers who
are who are completely happy to
wait you know eight business days for
the products they'll use our super saver
shipping offer which is free all they
have to do is meet a $25 order hurdle so
they're perfectly willing to save a few
things in their shopping cart until they
can meet that order hurdle they sort of
managed that it creates a little bit of
mental overhead for them but they're
they're okay with that and so that
becomes a great value proposition for
them and there's another set of
customers who think about this
completely differently they hate the
fact that there's this twenty five
dollar order hurdle they want to be able
to buy you know one thing when they see
it get it done have it common they want
it to come fast they don't want to have
to think about it they don't want to
have to try and optimize shipping costs
and in fact one of the things that
happens for that kind of customer too is
they create there's a kind of cognitive
dissonance or guilt that gets set up in
their head you know it they kind of like
since they can get the shipping for free
they feel like they should be getting
the shipping for free and so even though
you know maybe for them that's not
actually a rational economic
consideration this is another
convenience oriented feature that's been
on the website for a couple of years now
instant order update and this reminds
you that you've already bought something
and we get feedback from customers all
the time this is something that we
measured tested very very carefully and
it reduces sales there's just no
question about it that in the short term
is statistically significant way reduces
sales and we so we overruled that with
judgment and said even though we can't
do long duration longitudinal tests in
time like like a drug company would do
to test for toxicity and that kind of
thing where they do like a 10-year test
that those tests are just so expensive
to do we're gonna make it we're gonna
make a intuitive bat that having this
thing that reminds you that you already
bought something will actually will be
so beloved by customers that they'll be
one of the reasons they like amazon.com
and so and and in fact we do get
tremendous anecdotal response back from
customers saying they love this feature
little you know thank you note saying
about to buy the same music CD that I
bought a year ago and this is very real
I don't know you know some people are
more organized and have better memories
than others I definitely fall prey to
this in fact just yesterday I was
reading a blog that mentioned a walt
disney DVD on the back in the late 50s
or early 60s I can't remember where and
Walt Disney was very interested in space
and he hired Wernher von Braun and did a
whole series of television specials
about the exploration of space
starring Wernher von Braun and these
things have been collected on a DVD and
I read about this on this blog and I
thought my god this is so cool
I have to buy this and so I went to
amazon.com actually they were an
associate and so they had a link handy
for me and I clicked right through to
the detail page and there was my instant
order update I bought it a year ago and
I've never watched it I bought it and I
must have like you know put it somewhere
and so now I'm gonna go search for it
this is a real one - drew who's sitting
down here and told me that he almost
bought these earrings for his wife a
second time and it's a true story and so
I think in that case we that was really
a valuable service another convenience
oriented feature is giving people high
quality product information right on the
detail page and one of the great things
about this is an exempt this is a piece
of the detail page for the Segway and it
explains in great detail how this Segway
works and one of the great things about
the online model that we use is that a
lot of our best customer experience is a
fixed cost so if you have enough scale
if you have you know in so in the last
12 months we have these you know 47
million customers who have purchased
from amazon.com and if you have 47
million customers you get to amortize
that the cost of all this content across
that very large customer base and so
there's a sense in which you can have
your cake and eat it too if you look in
the physical world at physical world
retail stores the kind of high-touch
customer experience stores cannot have
the lowest cost and the reason for that
is that those stores the things that
generate high-touch customer experience
in the physical world are variable cost
things so when you double your sales you
double those costs our model when you
look at this kind of content or any of
the software features that we provide at
instant order update it's you know
somebody has to develop that and
maintain it and make it work but what it
would cost us the same to do that
development if we had a million
customers as it does if we have 47
million customers so that that that that
aspect of our model that we get to
transform customer experience into a
fixed cost instead of a variable cost is
really a key it's underappreciated
aspect of of what we do now this is also
for any company that wants to be
innovative absolutely critical thing to
do which is to not be distracted when
people tell you that this is stupid and
isn't going to work and people are
well-meaning and entrepreneurs and and
and and I've used that term in the most
broad way you know people who are
building people who are inventing have
to have this combination of stubbornness
and flexibility and the trick of course
is knowing which to use win but but what
you cannot do is be distracted by the
outside world you have to stay heads
down focused on customers and not let
external events distract you and Amazon
is a very good case of this this is
December of 1998 but and actually this
is a phrase that and I think Rob is in
the audience but this is not you Rob you
didn't write this
but this is the this is a case of in
1997 forced to research coined this term
and and Barnes & Noble had just launched
their online store and I thought that
Forrester had a very good point they
were saying and you know Amazon is this
two year old company they've had this
nice to your run but you know so now the
the big the big gorilla has come to town
and at the time we had annual revenues
of sixty million dollars a year we had a
hundred and twenty five employees and
Barnes & Noble had you know thirty
thousand employees and at that time I
don't know three billion dollars a year
in sales and so it didn't seem like an
even fight and and they coined this term
Amazon toast and and it was widely
picked up and you know the the and it
did bother the there's one feedback loop
here that has to be managed which is you
have to make sure that the the that you
have some all-hands meetings and that
you communicate to employees what this
you know should they be worried about
this or shouldn't they be worried about
this and in our case I thought this was
a very simple situation because the I
didn't think there was anything we could
do about what our competitors were going
to do and so you know we did have the
All Hands meeting and I asked all of our
125 employees to be terrified and to
wake up with their sheets drenched in
sweat every morning and I did I
carefully specified sweat and and but
that they should be afraid not of our
competitors but they should be afraid of
our customers because our customers are
the only ones who are going to ever give
us money and so that helps it actually
helps have that kind of customer focus
if your because it helps you stay heads
down you don't get worried about your
circular competitors are going to do
what your competitors are going to do
you can watch them you can learn from
them but you can't let them set your
strategy you have to do what you're
gonna do and you also can't let the
media set your strategy and and but you
do see that happen you can't
wallstreet set your strategy either this
is a year after Amazon ptosis is 19 May
of 1999 and this I have always been
amused by this but I'm uncomfortable
being misunderstood but this I have to
tell you my mom really hated this this
really bothered her she was so pissed
off about this this just that just
didn't like that caricature it really
bothered her so but anyway you just have
to ignore those outside influences you
can listen and kind of try to see if
there's any any any kernels of truth
that you can take and adapt there's no
reason to have a siege mentality but
that's those are the kind of reactions
you see you either see that people enter
this sort of siege mentality with
respect to external factors or they or
they're too responsive to these external
factors and the reality is you have to
take it with a grain of salt and you
know reexamine your strategy make sure
you really believe in it it's the right
one and stick to it that's the only way
you can invent because invention always
leads you down paths that people are
gonna think are weird it's sort of
obvious this is this is this is that a
CSI score and it's actually four years
running that we've had this highest
score so one of the things I mentioned
is the carbon dating and what happens in
the online is you in the well UNTAC in
general is you get you get so much
change and you have to sometimes look at
the change and see what you can invent
so why is things as Moore's Law which is
remarkable and it's variants for
bandwidth and and and storage but if you
look at disk space costs as against
example
disk space is 30 times cheaper today
than it was five years ago and so you
know that's just what happens when
things get twice as cheap every year for
five years and humans aren't good at
thinking in the kind of you know
exponential terms but this is really a
big deal and if you if you were to
picture a physical store it created that
when things change that rapidly it
actually creates a problem you have to
figure out what are we gonna do with all
that disk space because it's not you
know you can't just pocket the cost
savings you don't get enough value out
of that you have to say well if we can
use 30 terabytes of disk and that's a
reasonable thing to spend money on now
what could you do that would actually
benefit customers that use this 30 but
terabytes of disk and the one of the
things that we did was search inside the
book which uses about 30 terabytes of
disk because we keep the full images of
all the pages and we now have over
200,000 different books that are
completely searchable and you can view
the actual images of the books and and
and that it kind of the good news about
that is it's very beneficial to
customers and it soaks up a lot of this
now almost free disk space that you can
buy out in the world
another example is a nine let me just go
here which just launched again about a
week ago get a nine yellow pages we do a
search on optical this regular mouse
works too it's a lot easier to use and
one of the innovative things that the a
nine team did for their yellow pages is
take 20 million photos of over a million
different businesses in ten different
cities and they did that in a very cool
way I mean this in something you know
here if you go down the list here this
is optical in Seattle but you know the
map changes the little numbers
highlighted as you go over which think
it's a nice user interface to touch but
if we go down to optical illusions Inc
click on that
takes you to a detail page for optical
illusions Inc and you can kind of stroll
along the street here so here is you
know and you can zoom in on this picture
and next way this is kind of a cool
picture because this is you can see in
the reflection of this window that's the
vehicle that we took the picture from
and I also I like the way this guy is in
motion it's just kind of fun and that
you can't barely see her but there's a
woman behind him you can just sort of
see her see her shoes we have it's only
been up a week and you know but if you
take 20 million 20 million photographs
of a million different businesses we've
already gotten lots of contacts from
people you know who have found
themselves in these pictures and if they
request to be removed we remove them but
but this is this is a pretty cool use of
technology and again it's looking at
what's changed in the world because one
of the most interesting things about
this is is how they did it and you can
keep going by the way I can click here
and it will take me you know down the
next street I can just keep walking down
this street okay so how did they do this
should I go to the back to the
PowerPoint alright here's the truck
they're there more than one of these
that is a a camera a digital camera
mounted on the top of the truck and when
they first started doing it their first
tests were done with not with SUVs but
with regular cars and and the the camera
was not in any kind of enclosure but
they attracted too much attention and
people would like smile for the camera
or do more profane things for the camera
so they've solved that problem by
getting a taller vehicle and you know
putting the camera in an enclosure so it
just sort of looks like some luggage on
the roof and people don't notice it and
the so let's see here's one of the you
guys if you've been to Times Square you
may have seen this guy he's out there
all the time
I think he's called The Naked Cowboy
he's been doing this for years and years
and years he was there
he's been there at least for eight years
but maybe longer I don't know and I
think TGI Fridays has hired him now as a
sort of mascot but anyway they captured
the naked cowboy in Times Square
let me is this when I go to the video
all right let me see we're gonna do this
the hard way because it's not working
the easy way all right watch this I
should actually let me pause this for a
sec this let me give you a little setup
so this is some some of the actual
footage from this camera this is a just
to give you the this is a camera that is
connected to a laptop that has a GPS in
it and so the Jeep the car just drives
around and the driver doesn't have to do
anything except make sure all the
equipment is running properly and it
just takes you know a bunch of frames
per second and and and and and and the
car knows where it is at all times so
this now we one of the cities that we
did we did over ten cities but one of
them was Washington DC and and and the
driver whose name is Josh in this case
had a fairly interesting experience
because the camera broke and needed some
adjustments
it just got jiggled or something and
needed to be fixed and remounted so
which happens occasionally so he didn't
think anything of it he stopped the car
he got out and he started to fix the
camera but unfortunately for Josh he
happened to stop right in front of the
State Department and and unfortunately
just to make matters a little more
complicated it was the day before the
election and so Washington was at its
highest state of alert and fortunately
this entire incident was captured on
video and it's kind of fun to watch so
there's Josh he's getting out of the car
gonna work on the camera little but he
sees somebody's coming he's reaching for
his cell phone now trying to call Amazon
become legal now there are two of them
they're very curious why josh is
photographing the State Department
here's the third one
this here's the here's the fourth one
and if you can catch glimpses of Josh's
face you can see that he is a little
stressed by the way to at a certain
point here you can see the woman in the
red hair I think it's the one sort of in
charge she's trying to calm Josh down
and she says something to him like it's
not like we're accusing you of having a
bomb or anything which didn't really
work oh yeah here's the great they take
a picture of Josh and the and they they
actually were were
they may actually were very friendly to
Josh and he explained the whole thing
and they made some phone calls and
confirmed his strange but true story
about what was going on and the whole
incident only took like 45 minutes and
and and Josh was sent on his way to
photograph the rest of Washington DC
let's go back okay but all of those
things okay all those things are if you
look at what all the problems that had
to be solved to do something like get
that you know the GPS integrated with
the digital camera and get those in
trucks and then solve all these little
point problems that people were noticing
the camera and so on
that's what innovating is all about it
really is those kinds of problems and
the great thing about this is at
amazon.com is I do very little of this
so you know we have a culture where
people in small teams can go off and do
these relatively low-cost experiments
and try to build neat things if you want
to have an innovative company the single
most important thing even ahead of
minimizing the cost of experimentation
is to make sure that you're selecting
the people correctly on the way in and
so you need to hire people who like to
build who like to invent and you need to
make sure that they'd like to do that at
all granularities you know sometimes you
come across these people who are only
interested in inventing it the at the
grandest sort of whiteboard level and
they actually can't make progress in the
real world you know they're unwilling to
figure out how to mount the camera on
top of the truck and mounting the camera
on top of the truck turns out to be
incredibly important this is I've mostly
included this slide to demonstrate my
true pedigree as a geek this is me in
fourth grade and most of you in this
room are far too young to recognize that
device that I'm sitting in front of
but I was I'm one of the only people I
know who had access to a combined who
had access to a computer in fourth grade
I went the school that I went to in
Houston got this a company donated this
teletype and also donated some excess
mainframe time sharing time that they
had and so we got this thing one day and
none of the teachers knew how to use it
and nobody knew how to use it but had
manuals and that that phone receiver is
it called an acoustic modem and you
actually put the it's a 300 baud modem
and the all the programs were stored on
paper tape which you'd punch holes in
and we me and about three other kids
started staying after school and and
learned how to program this this
mainframe computer and store our
programs and our very primitive programs
on paper tape and that went on for
several months until we discovered that
the mainframe was pre-programmed
to play Star Trek and pretty much that's
all we did with the computer after that
we would stay after school the teachers
were like boy these kids just love
computers it was this really cool Star
Trek game where you know the it's all
done it's teletype on paper and it would
print a little I think it was a nine by
nine grid and somewhere in that nine by
nine grid like you know an asterisk
would be a star and a plus sign would be
a Klingon ship and you had to do it was
a simulation game and you had to like
you know you had limited resources like
you had only so much power and gonna
decide how to allocate that power
between shields and engines and phasers
and it was actually unbelievably fun and
so but you've got it this is you've got
to find people who are passionate about
building this is our first employment ad
at amazon.com we post this on Usenet and
and we asked for exactly what we wanted
and and you know the the technology in
computer science people
and businesspeople who are interested in
technology have always been most
important so you must have experience
designing and building large and complex
yet maintainable systems and you should
be able to do so in about one third of
time that most competent people think
possible and by the way as a total aside
you'll see that the name of the company
at the time was Cadabra that was the
first name of the company and Cadabra
was a terrible name
because while driving across the country
is my wife driving I called an attorney
in Seattle and asked the attorney to if
he could incorporate the company so it
would already be ready by the time we
arrived and he said sure this is no
problem by the way this attorney was my
friend's divorce attorney so it wasn't
this wasn't like Wilson Sonsini or
anything you know this was and and we
said sure you know what do you want the
name of the company to be and I you know
was well proud of myself for having
anticipated that question and I said
Cadabra and he said cadaver I knew right
then that my name choice was not gonna
survive for long either no no no Cadabra
like abracadabra okay so he about three
months later we changed the name to
amazon.com and that was chosen because
it started with the letter A and at that
time all of the lists online were
alphabetized and it was also the domain
name was available and it was it worked
internationally and it was short and
easy to spell so there were a whole
bunch of good features of that